[Music]
thank you very much please I am thrilled
to host the Wounded Warrior Project
it's been a long relationship I've had
and the soldier ride is something very
very special a few people could do it
including me I hate to admit I hate to
admit that general but in truth we're
deeply honored to be in the presence of
true American heroes I want to thank our
great vice president Mike Pence and
Karen pence for being with us today
thank you Michael
and theirs is really a fierce devotion I
can tell you that speaking I deal with
Mike and Karen and they have a fierce
devotion to America's veterans and we
all do and thank you very much we're all
so grateful to be joined by acting
defense secretary Patrick Shanahan
Patrick thank you very much great job
you're doing
100% of the caliphate so that's that was
great that was one of our early
assignments right a few
so I appreciate it great job man General
Counsel of Veteran Affairs Jim burn Jim
thank you very much Jim
and Army Vice Chief of Staff General
James McConville James thank you James
I also want to thank two great
congressmen for being here and if we had
room we would had a lot more fill row
and James Baird thank you very much
and they're having a good day I'm having
a good day too
it was called no collusion no
obstruction
there never was by the way and there
never will be and we do have to get to
the bottom of these things I will say
and this should never happened I say
this in front of my friends wounded
warriors and I just call them warriors
because we just shook hands and they
look great they look so good
so beautiful but I say it in front of my
friends this should never happen to
another president again this hoax
should never happen to another president
again thank you with us on stage today
are the wounded warriors from the Air
Force the army the Navy the Coast Guard
the National Guard and the Marine Corps
each of you is a living testament to the
outstanding determination persistence
and patriotism that made this the
greatest nation ever to exist
on the face of the earth and as you know
we're spending the biggest number of
dollars we've ever spent not even close
you know that very well general 700
billion my first year I won't even tell
you how much higher than before we got
here
and then 716 and this year were even
trying to up it were rebuilding our
military like never before brand-new
fighter jets brand new ships of all
kinds every soldier has the best
equipment in the army we're even getting
new uniforms and those beautiful new
uniforms with the belt was a big deal
the belt and if you think those uniforms
were inexpensive they were very
expensive very but they wanted it and we
got it we have equipment now like we've
never had before we have research going
on for the new and greatest equipment in
the world nobody is even close nobody
can do what we can do and we're at a
level that we have really never been so
a lot of lot of progress has been made
when I came in with Mike we were a
depleted Armed Forces we were depleted
we had planes that were 5060 years old
we had things that going on that you
wouldn't believe that the general knew
that general I think we all knew and we
weren't happy about it and we took it
and I'm a big budget person but there's
one thing more important than the budget
maybe a couple of things but there's one
thing in particular and that's our
military and our defense of our nation
because without the defense of our
nation our budget doesn't matter and we
have done a real job and I think when I
go to the bases and I'm with the
soldiers and the sailors and everybody
the Marines we we spend a lot of time
with Marines the other day Coast Guard
doing the most advanced icebreaker in
the world they were trying to get it for
20 years they couldn't get it we're
doing it it is expensive I will say
built in the USA by the way but all of
the things that we're getting and I
think in particular the Air Force with
the planes we're ordering vast numbers
of f-35 fighter jets I've tried to keep
the price as low as possible I got
involved personally I don't even know if
I'm supposed to do it I'll probably get
in trouble because I cut the price you
know but we cut it very substantially
very very substantially and the f-18s
and every kind of plane you can think of
the bombers the tankers we have the
greatest equipment in the world
everybody wants it and we only give it
to those that are working with us and
they pay for it by the way that's always
nice you know in the old days they
weren't paying so much now at least they
pay and they're happy about it they
respect us again they respect our
country again today America proudly
salutes you and all of your fellow
warriors you are incredible warriors and
when I took pictures just a little while
ago some of the guys walked in where are
they are they here where are they they
walked in they said hello there were so
could you stand please where are they
what happened okay they're there but I
had some out here to everybody stand
please please
[Applause]
this great admiration in this room and
all over the country for all of you for
all of you and for all of you we really
appreciate it very much thank you very
much great job we ran all of your
courage and we are forever grateful for
your noble sacrifice I also extend my
deep gratitude to the amazing military
spouses and the families that are here
today a lot of families here stand up
placed our spouses stand up
without the families the spouses it
doesn't work doesn't work not the same
you love sustains our warriors and our
nation and we want to thank you so much
you are incredible people we're also
delighted to have a distinguished World
War two veteran in attendance corporal
James Blane who was wounded in action at
the famous Battle of Iwo Jima and that
was a battle where's James hi James
thank you James a real hero we're
honored by your presence thank you
tomorrow the Wounded Warriors onstage
with me will complete the final miles of
their more than 30 mile soldier ride
through Maryland and Virginia
when battlegrounds all over the world
these brave Patriots risked their lives
and shed their blood to defend our
nation our people and our great American
flag nobody defends our country like
those people representing all others but
those people in the room today very very
special group here at home they've
beaten back injury and illness in some
cases beyond anybody's wildest
imagination
and persevered through pain and
adversity and hardship the word comeback
greatest comeback but it's a word even
beyond it's just courage
pure and simple courage the legacy of
service is a gift to every single
American through their example we
witness the daily triumph of the human
spirit and the unmatched valor of the
American patriot among our wounded
warriors here today is 23 year old
Justin day while clearing towns in
Afghanistan of terrorist fighters in
July
Justin stepped on an AED not good since
then he has endured more than a dozen
surgeries including the amputation of
his right leg today Justin continues his
recovery at Walter Reed where by the way
they do an incredible job I'm there a
lot to say hello to the folks they do
unbelievable work there's nothing that
I've ever seen like they do and they
have cutting-edge technology they have
the best doctors and that's why I think
I'm gonna have to be president for many
many years because I don't know I never
want to use a regular doctor again
one of the benefits I get Walter rate
they have great doctors right I mean
they're just incredible people and Aubry
is here Justin's wife and or where he's
where's stand up please
a little bad news he looks like Justin
do bad
thank you thank you very much
congratulations just days ago Justin got
on a bike for the first time since his
injury tomorrow he will finish the
grueling course alongside of his fellow
warriors and it is really grueling
Justin your story like so many others in
this room is an inspiration to all of us
and to all Americans honestly I really
think it's an inspiration all over the
world people right now are watching all
over the world also with us today is
Lieutenant General Mike Remington who
serves as CEO of the Wounded Warrior
Project and has done an incredible job
hasn't been there that long but boy you
took it and you just what a job you've
done what a job
in a Malden general Wennington will
introduce another truly remarkable
Wounded Warrior Jose Ramos before we
hear from general Huntington and mr.
Ramos I want to thank every veteran in
the room for your patriotic service and
selfless really I mean the selfless
sacrifice that you put out on a daily
basis you are so respected so loved by
our country you are the guardians of
American liberty you are the foundation
of American strength and you are the
greatest source of American courage
honor and pride that we have so I just
want to say to everybody may God bless
you may God bless our incredible which
is what they are wounded warriors and
all of our veterans and may God bless
our military and very importantly our
great country the United States of
America thank you
so general you step up and say thank you
thank you mr. president
president Trump vice president mrs.
Penn's secretary Shanahan cabinet and
congressional leaders fellow veterans
service organizations and the room is
packed with many of the leaders from our
veteran service organizations that we
work with together most importantly our
warriors and families thank you all for
joining us today
on behalf of the entire team at Wounded
Warrior Project we're honored today to
celebrate this exceptional group of
wounded warriors standing behind me it's
truly an honor to be here at the White
House for soldier ride DC our 12th year
in a row how about that 12th year in a
row and we're grateful for having such a
great group of American patriots behind
me as the president said yesterday the
wounded warriors behind me rode through
the streets of Annapolis Maryland and
the campus of the u.s. Naval Academy
where they received incredible
encouragement and recognition for their
service and sacrifice tomorrow though
right through Northern Virginia an
uphill hilly ride and is going to be
raining about that continuing to
challenge themselves physically while
strengthening bonds of friendship and
cohesion with each other and with the
Grateful citizens they'll meet along the
way we know that with the right support
wounded veterans regularly overcome the
adversity of their injuries and either
return to duty in uniform or leave full
productive lives as citizen leaders in
the communities in which they settle and
that's really what today is all about
providing a venue for wounded service
members to bond continue healing and
realize that we are all here for them
mr. president thank you for honoring and
empowering our nation's finest and for
the work you have done and will continue
to do on behalf of our military and our
veteran community I now have the honor
of introducing our next speaker hospital
corpsman Jose Ramos one of Wounded
Warrior project's legislative directors
from our office right here in the
nation's capital a native of El Paso
Texas
Jose joined the Navy in 2000 to become a
corpsman a medic where he was assigned
to several marine corps infantry
battalions as their platoon doc Jose
served one tour in Afghanistan and two
tours in Iraq and you can only imagine
the difficult conditions
Jose faced while he was deployed
multiple times and in very difficult
circumstances in 2004 Jose was hit by a
rocket while serving as a member of a
Marine sniper team his injuries were
near-fatal causing devastating damage to
his left arm
despite his critical injuries Jose was
not only able to direct a fellow service
member in applying a tourniquet to his
arm but he continued to assist other
wounded personnel before he was himself
medevacked Jose thankfully recovered and
retired from the military in 2005 and
amazingly within months of his injuries
he ran and completed the New York City
Marathon Jose is a former member of the
u.s. para triathlon team and a former
appointee to the President's Commission
on care for America's returning wounded
warriors he is also a steadfast advocate
for his brothers and sisters in arms and
is joined today by his beautiful wife
Jodi and children Donovan and Luke
sitting right here in the front row
let's give Jose a big round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
well first and foremost I want to say
thank you to our general Reddington for
those kind of card remarks and for
recognizing my beautiful wife and my
children you know my nine-year-old asked
me if I can bring him to the White House
one day and I did today and now I just
gotta make sure the capital with
capitals win the playoffs and I think
I'm good for the year so no it truly is
an honor and a privilege to be here
today to be at the White House amongst
all our distinguished guests and
particularly amongst the Warriors behind
me not too long ago I was standing in
their shoes and it feels like it was
yesterday you are obviously a few years
back but that definitely brings back
some memories I also want to thank the
White House staff for putting this
together it's a lot of work and we
really appreciate what you've done
soldier ride is just one of the many
programs with a where a project has but
it's a program that's particularly
special to me it's it's played a
significant part in my life and as
general Denson indicated I joined the
Navy in 2000 and 2004 I was seeing
myself serving in my third tour overseas
as a corpsman attached to Marine sniper
team when I was a severely injured by a
rocket attack fast forward a little bit
on Wall Street waking up recovering you
know going through the process as
anybody who was injured at the time and
unbeknownst to me you know there was a
group of friends somewhere in New York
coming up with this crazy idea how about
we write a bycicle across the country
right to raise awareness and some money
for a young organization doing great
work and that was the Wounded Warrior
Project soon afterwards in 2004 Chris
Carney decided to do just that and he
wrote over 5,000 miles across the
country from coast to coast and in the
second or following that he decided to
do it again this time going in the
opposite direction that was really the
birth of soldier right right that year
we had two leg amputees join him to
service members still at wall street
ryan heath and so they trekked starting
from san diego all the way across back
to towards backs towards new york on
their route they stopped at Walter Reed
where they met up with and picked up a
group of newly injured service members
to join him the rest of the way and I
was one of the privileged to be able to
join through that route we did about 400
miles in about seven days and in that
ride I learned three important lessons
number one Pennsylvania is not flat and
it's extremely hilly and if it wasn't
for the Amish pastries in the Yingling I
don't think I would have made it to the
stage I did say I was a corpsman with
the Marine Corps number two going
downhill full-speed with one arm is not
easy did not realize that end oh by the
way if you're going to go on long bike
rides make sure you're wearing cycling
shorts and make sure they're not that
make sure they're not inside-out and
number three the most important lesson
of them all is no matter how difficult
the challenge is whether you fall down
or crash whether you need to get off the
bike or walk right or
if it seems like the miles never end if
there's someone holding you or helping
you get back up walking along your side
with you if there's someone supporting
you and helping you realize the finish
line is just a little bit further
anything is possible
right those days grinding it out on
those roads made me realize they made us
all realize that recovery takes takes
time and it takes hard work but at the
same time if you're willing to put in
the time and with the support you can
overcome everything you might fail but
you will eventually succeed now it's not
possible unless you have a great
supporting team next year that's Wounded
Warrior Project does and it also
provides great company with you so
anything you set to accomplish it's
possible and anything that you want to
do you can't even you so choose to so
mr. president I wanted to to again say
we appreciate your generosity in your
hospitality and your willingness to have
us here today to help us remind our
nation and our fellow Americans that our
nation our nation's wounded warriors
still need our compassion and our
support and that the mission of Wounded
Warrior Project is to support them along
the way on their right no law no matter
how long it takes
Thank You Jose Jose Ramos is the epitome
of what it means to be a wounded warrior
and as and as we say in our land he's
truly living the logo of a warrior that
starts being carried off the battlefield
and through his recovery and
rehabilitation is carrying others in
their recovery so Jose thank you for
your dedication and your commitment and
mr. president a small token of
appreciation for you and the White House
staff please accept this small memento
on behalf of all of us and especially
the warriors standing behind me
[Applause]
well this is really beautiful this will
find a permanent place at least for six
years in the oval office is that okay I
was going to joke general say at least
for 10 or 14 years but we would cause
bedlam if I said
so we'll say six I want to thank you
very much this is fantastic
[Applause]
until the president has departed the
East Room